das hier sind die fluffigsten Pancakes
der Welt das ist wirklich das einzige
Pancake Rezept was man braucht und die
Geheimzutat heißt Buttermilch wir
brauchen außerdem noch mehl Zucker
Vanillezucker Backpulver Butter zwei
Eier und eine Prise Salz wir fangen an
indem wir einfach alles was trocken ist
in eine Schüssel geben die Mengenangaben
stehen wie immer in der Beschreibung und
dann rühren wir einmal um jetzt kommen
die flüssigen Zutaten dazu wir beginnen
mit der Buttermilch die Buttermilch
macht das Ganze nicht nur fluffig
sondern gibt auch so einen bestimmten
charakteristischen Geschmack dazu
unglaublich gut geschmolzene Butter Eier
dazu und ein r die Pfanne ist vorgeheizt
wir geben ein bisschen Butter rein und
lassen die schmilzen und dann können wir
auch schon unseren pancakeeteig
reingeben so ein kleines bisschen immer
gleich viel und dann muss man ein
bisschen Geduld haben bis man wendet
ungefähr 5 Minuten später sind die
Pancakes fertig das sieht man daran dass
der Teig oben schon fast durchgebacken
ist und sich diese kleinen fluffigen
Bläschen gebildet haben und schöne Farbe
wir sind auf ein guten Weg und jetzt
machen wir uns einen richtig schönen
Stapel fertig